Today's video is brought to you by innovative language,
the creators of Finnish pod one Oh one,
click the link in the description to check out their huge collection of audio
and video lessons for students of all levels. Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to compare two languages that are closely related to each other,
and similar in many ways, but also quite different from each other.
With limited mutual intelligibility.
I'm talking about two non-Indian European languages have Northern Europe,
Finnish and Estonian Finnish,
and dystonias are both members of the FinTech group of languages.
Along with Karelian ludic,
VIPs Ingredion vo-tech and Lavonia.
Their most recent common ancestor language was late [inaudible] around 2000
years ago. Finnick is a branch of the erratic language family.
So they are both more distantly related to Hungarian as well since Finnish
and Astonian have been developing in different directions for 2000 years.
There are now fairly different with Astonian being much more innovative while
Finnish is more conservative. In other words, Estonian has changed more.
They're not mutually intelligible for the most part.
Aside from basic general vocabulary,
Estonian speakers generally understand finish better than finished speakers.
Understand Astonian because of exposure to Finnish media.
The way I understand that this is much less the case among the young generations
today,
let's look at a few common phrases in either language and see what's similar and
what's different about them. Hello in Finnish, Hey, and in Estonia.
Better or better beast.
This word literally means health. The T here is a positive case.
Inflection positive is the case used for direct objects when they are partial
object, rather than complete ones
is a contraction of, of East.
But finish also has the formal word for hello,
which literally means healthy.
This is a cognate with the Estonian word data-based except [inaudible] is an
adjective rather than a noun in Estonia is
used with many greetings. Well in Finnish is used,
is Stony and has a cognate of this word. Yeah, they both mean good.
Good morning in finish.
This now is in the positive case and is a literary word for morning in finish
in a stolen ghost here.
You can see that these two words are cognates and both come from [inaudible]
whole men, but the Estonian word is in the LA TIF case,
which is used with the sense of from or out of good day or
good afternoon in Finnish. And in Estonian
again, here, you can see that these two words are cognates.
These cognates reveal an important difference between Finnish and Estonian
Finnish uses vowel harmony while Astonian no longer uses vowel harmony,
except in some archaic expressions in Finnish,
there are three classes of vowels, front vowels, neutral vowels,
and back vowels. If a word content's front vowels,
it cannot contain back vowels and vice versa.
This also applies to the word suffixes by Eva.
This is a front vowel. So aside from this neutral vowel,
the other vowel is also a front vowel here.
We see a front vowel and a neutral vowel,
but there's a back vowel in the suffix.
This word doesn't exhibit the same vowel harmony as the finished word,
but it's worth noting that vowel harmony may be seen in Southern Estonian
dialect.
Good evening in Finnish and in Estonian
dust. In this case, these phrases contain no cognate words.
What's your name and finish [inaudible] word for word.
What your name is.
One is the genitive inflection of the personal pronoun. See, now see,
moon also has a short form that is used in informal speech.
[Inaudible] on in Estonia.
And Messina and, and just like I can finish.
Estonian also has a short form of the genitive pronoun miso Nemean whether we
use the long forms or the short forms,
you can see that the Finnish and Estonian sentences are pretty close to each
other.
One difference is the word for what another difference is the form of the word
for name in finished.
The basic nominative form is Nimi like in Estonian, but in finish,
there are special possessive forms of the nominative.
When there's a genitive pronoun to show possession,
a corresponding possessive suffix is added to the end of the now.
And in this case, it changes the final vowel though, that doesn't always happen.
The full suffix C is used in formal written finish wireless shortened.
Suffix is usually used in spoken finish, or the suffix is dropped.
[inaudible] when the suffix is dropped,
it's more like the Estonian sentence possessive suffix has disappeared from
Astonian in the 17th century. So, whereas in finished,
you can say a possessive sentence without the genitive personal pronoun in
Estonian, you need it. For example, in the sentences,
meaning my name is in Finnish Nima. Any own here.
There's no genitive pronoun, but there's a possessive suffix in Estonian Mino.
Nemean here. There's a genitive pronoun, but there's no possessive suffix,
false friends. So far,
we've seen that some words are different and other words are cognates.
While those cognates often have different forms or different inflectional forms,
but as with most languages that are closely related to each other,
there are also some false friends, cognates that look and sound similar,
but actually have different meanings. For example,
in Finnish gory star means to decorate the Estonian word,
goody STEMA means to clean the core meaning of these words is to make beautiful.
So you can see how that developed into both of their present meanings in
Finnish. Maya means a shelter or a Treehouse. And in Estonia one,
Maya is the regular word for house.
The finished word horny means a room. The Estonian.
Word means a big.
Building. The Finnish word. It means a cabin,
but a cabin on a boat. The Estonian word,
who means a hut or a shack, both of these words are dramatic.
Lone words,
the Finnish one from Swedish and the Estonian one from old high German.
The finished word means Bible. The Estonian.
Word means book.
The word for a book and finish is,
and the word for Bible and Astonian is finish,
is much more conservative in its vocabulary,
meaning that there have been strong efforts to use Finnish words or coin new
words from finished routes instead of adopting loan words for modern objects and
concepts. For example, in Estonia, the word for telephone is
finish, had the word [inaudible], but replaced it with full hailing.
Estonian contains many lone words,
especially from middle low German and German finish.
It sticks to its finished routes for most of these,
the word for kitchen in finish gate and in Estonian,
the finished word was coined in the 19th century from the word meaning to cook
plus a suffix that forms nouns from verbs.
The Estonian word comes from middle low German where finished does use lone
words. They're often from Swedish,
as we saw in a previous pair of false friends.
Another example is the words for doctor in finish lack Addie,
which comes from Swedish and an Estonian artist,
which comes from middle low German grammar finish and dystonia
have many grammatical features in common,
both Finnish and Estonian are synthetic languages.
That means that meaning can be added to a sentence by adding additional
morphemes to a word rather than adding additional words,
both have a combination of a gluten aiding and fusional elements though.
Astonian has become somewhat less synthetic with the loss of some inflectional
affixes, like the loss of the possessive suffix as we saw before.
Another example is that Estonian verbs in their negative conjugation have no
affixes showing person making subject pronouns necessary.
Unlike in Finnish, neither language has grammatical gender.
There are no masculine, feminine neuter distinctions,
neither language has articles like that. Or ah, in English, for example,
in Finnish, Bala means either the house or our house, and also in Estonian.
Maya means either the house or our house,
both Finnish and Estonian have both prepositions and post positions.
Neither language has a separate future tense.
The present is also used for the future. For example,
these sentences can mean either I study English or I will study English in
Finnish [inaudible] England and in Estonian,
But the Estonian sentence actually needs some more context in order to be
interpreted as future tents. If you add an adverb of time like tomorrow,
then we'll know it's future tense rather than present tense.
[Inaudible].
Without that context, the word HOK con could be used to indicate the future.
It literally means start, but as used, like going to an English.
Mohawk and English.
Finnish and dystonia have similar case systems,
Finnish has 15 cases while Astonian has 14, though,
there are two others that are sometimes included as well.
There's no accusative case on the Estonian list, but as unfinished,
the accusative form is the same as either the nominative or the genitive form
grammatical differences. The inflections are different between the languages.
Of course, we saw some examples of that before in verb conjugations.
And in case inflections,
Estonian syntax has some influence from low German and German. For example,
Astonian often uses post positions, whereas in finish a case would be used,
for example, the phrase, meaning on the table and finish.
And in Estonia LOA, the finished noun is in the [inaudible] case,
which gives the meaning of aunt or at in Estonian. There's a separate word,
a post position,
meaning on in Finnish subject pronouns are normally left out
for the first and second person except for emphasis.
But the third person is required.
That's in the written formal language in casual speech.
The pronouns are normally used though. Not always in Estonian.
They're more often left out in casual speech. For example,
these sentences mean I read a book first and formal finish me and Lewin
[inaudible] and an informal finish [inaudible].
And in Estonian with the pronouns.
Malaga is in drama to lobby and without the pronoun, no guys in drama to lobby.
And finish the use of the pronoun,
depends more on the register with the pronoun normally dropped in formal written
finish, but included in spoken, finish in Astonian the use of the pronoun.
Doesn't really depend on the register.
It's normal to either use or drop the pronoun in both formal written and spoken
Estonian. One other difference here is that an Estonian,
the word lobby is necessary because the object here is a whole object.
Like the accusative case.
It adds the meaning of through like I read through the whole book,
this word would be unnecessary. If the noun was in the positive case,
referring to only part of the book next,
we're going to simply dive into some sentences and see what we find these
sentences mean. I study literature in university in finish
[inaudible] I,
I study literature in university and in a story.
[Inaudible] just word for word. Yeah.
I study in university literature first.
Notice that the finish sentence contains a subject pronoun while the Estonian
sentence doesn't remember that in either language people can use or drop the
pronoun,
but in speech it's normally used in finish while it's more often dropped and
spoken Estonian. Next, we see a pair of cognates, meaning study will.
Be skilling the bin. There's.
An interesting difference here.
The finished verb has a suffix that makes it frequent dative,
meaning it shows a repeated action.
It changes the meaning of the verb from learn to study.
But if we remove the suffix, it's a lot more like the Estonian word open.
The Estonian word can be used as it is with the meaning of study,
even though it also means learn. Next, the words for literature are cognates.
Both are in the positive case. The case used for partial direct objects.
In this case, the person doesn't study literature in all its entirety.
That would be impossible.
The person studies only part of the literature available.
So the positive cases used, but obviously,
even though the same cases used in both languages,
the infectional forms are rather different. Next,
the words for a university are different though. Both are in the NSF case,
which adds the meaning of in note that the inflection of the finished word is an
abbreviated colloquial form.
It matches the informality of the sentence shown by the short pronoun.
And one more sentence, if you drove more slowly,
I would be able to read the map and finish. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
Word for word it's.
If you would drive more slowly than I would be able to
read map and in Astonia.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Word for word it's. If you, more slowly you would drive,
I would be able to map read first. We see different words.
Meaning if here finish has no pronoun,
which tells us this is likely more formal finish in Estonian.
The pronoun is present, which is common in both formal and informal registers.
Next, we see two different verbs, meaning drive,
but both are in the second person, singular conditional.
I'm sure you notice the difference in word order.
This is interesting because in Estonia, the verb comes at the end of the,
if clause,
this likely shows the influence of low German or old high German in German and
low German.
The conjugated verb comes at the end of subordinate clauses of which if clauses
are one type, if we skip ahead to the second part of the sentence,
the main clause, we also see word order that looks dramatic.
The auxiliary verb is at the beginning and the lexical verb comes at the end of
the clause.
The auxiliary verb is not in second position as in German or low German because
the subject pronoun is dropped here. But we did see that word order before.
And this sense.
Mohawk and English. Yeah.
Here, the conjugated verb is in the second position.
And the second verb comes at the end as in German or low German.
Next, we see two different comparative adverbs.
Meaning more slowly in Finnish adverbs are formed by adding steep to
the inflecting form of the adjective. Then to form the comparative adverb.
Steet is replaced by mean in a Stoney.
The STEM of adverbs is the genitive singular form of the adjective. To that.
We add the suffix LT then to make the adverb comparative,
you remove that ending and add malt next in the finished sentence,
we see Nene meaning then to show the outcome of a condition. But in Estonia,
that's not used. There is a word that can be used.
Cease serves the same function, but the sentence is fine without it in Finnish,
it's better to include the word Nene and the sentence would say sound a bit
strange without it. Next, we see two different verbs.
Meaning I would be able to both are in the first person,
singular conditional mood. Next we have two cognitive verbs meaning to read,
but these two verbs reveal a grammatical difference between finished and
dystonia.
The finished verb is a third active infinitive in the elites of case finish
has five different infinitive forms. And this one is used in verb.
Chan's like this Estonian has only two types of infinitive,
the Maya infinitive and the die infinitive. This one is the die infinitive.
The die infinitive is used when something may or may not actually occur.
Whereas the Maya infinitive is used for things that are certain,
the [inaudible] is used in sentences, meaning things like she can,
or he may, or we want et cetera, because the action is not certain.
And after that, we have cognate words for map both in the positive case,
but with different inflectional forms, as you can see,
Finnish and dystonia function very similarly and their shared roots are obvious,
but it's also obvious that they split off from each other a very long time ago.
Estonian is by far the more innovative language and readily open to changes
while Finnish is much more conservative, at least standard finish.
If we introduced finished dialects into the comparison,
there might be more similarities with Estonian standard Astonian was based more
on Northern Estonian dialects as they were spoken.
Whereas standard finish was based more on conservative forms that were common to
all or most finished dialects.
The question of the day for speakers of Finnish and Estonian.
How well do you understand the other language?
Do you think exposure to the other language would be enough to get used to it
and understand it for other people?
What's your impression of these two languages? How similar to they seem to you?
If you're in the student learning finish,
I recommend you click the link in the description to check out finished pod one
Oh one.
They have hundreds of audio and video lessons with full transcripts for students
of all levels,
sign up for a free account and give it a try special thanks to my Patrion
supporters, especially these wonderful people right here on the screen.
They are the top tier Patrion supporters of this channel.
So many extra special thanks.
To them and to everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.